how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
everything relating to the MCU Nova has
been a character that many many fans
have been wanting in the MCU for a very
long time now and fans were really
disappointed when they found out that
Nova was actually supposed to be in the
opening scene of Avengers infinity war
but things are looking up for us because
it looks like Nova is finally going to
be coming to the MCU and it looks like
it could be in phase 5 so we'll talk
about everything you need to know about
this new report that says Nova is going
to be entering the MCU and we'll also
talk about that Nova deleted scene that
we never saw an Avengers infinity war if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all Marvel content and so
you can enter this week's giveaway an
Iron Man Funko pop and ends tomorrow so
be sure to subscribe it like and leave a
comment down below so today's report
comes to us from the Illuminati calm the
Illuminati has been very accurate with a
lot of recent leaks they put out
specifically the one about Christian
Bale playing the villain in for love and
thunder they first broke the news saying
that he was going to be in the film and
then they broke the news again saying
that he was going to be the villain all
of which of course came true so very
reputable and today they have a new
report they say that Kevin Feige
and Marvel Studios are presently
developing a nova solo project their
report reads as follows
according to a recent listing Marvel
Studios is in the early stages of
planning a project centered around Nova
this could be either a solo movie or a
TV show while it's their sources best
bet that it is in fact a movie in the
MCS future slate for phase 5 or later
however there is no absolute
confirmation that this could be a film
although it is expected to be a film
they say it could be fluid right now
meaning Marvel hasn't exactly decided on
whether or not they want to make it a
film or a Disney Plus show the report
says that right now under the listing
Marvel head Kevin Feige is indeed listed
as the sole producer while no other
talent is formally attached at the
moment so what this basically means is
that Kevin Feige has decided that he
wants Nova in the MCU in one way or
another be that a movie or a show or if
he decides they could even throw him in
a movie like guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 or Thor love and thunder he is
a
Kosmic character but based off of this
report it does seem like he's going to
get either his own movie or show all to
himself it's going to be centered around
Nova now an infinity war they almost
introduced him we found out an Avengers
infinity war from Thor when he was
talking to the guardians of the galaxy
that Thanos obtained the power stone by
decimating Xander he completely
destroyed all of Xander but we did not
see this in the film however there was a
version where we did see this and this
version is more than likely going to be
Nova's introduction into the MCU and be
his origin story the Nova Corps played a
very huge role in the guardians of the
galaxy
so Marvel has been planning on
introducing Nova to the MCU for a pretty
long time now now to know Nova's powers
you kind of have to understand how the
Nova force works
the Nova force is a power that is shared
between all of the members of the Nova
Corps now in the comics when all of the
Nova Corps are killed except for one
person ramen day all of the power of the
Nova force goes to that one person
so that person gets immense power so
what's likely going to happen in the MCU
how Nova becomes Nova and gets his power
is that afters and ARS completely wiped
away by Thanos there's probably going to
be one survivor this survivor will
inherit all of the Nova force and this
person will either become Nova or choose
who Nova is in the comics there's one
version of Nova who is Richard rider
with the last surviving member of
Xander's elite Nova Corps rom and a is
dying he selects New York high-school
student Richard Rider to replace him
Richard riders given the uniform and
powers of a Nova Centurion but little
instruction on how to use them calling
himself Nova he becomes a super hero and
he eventually goes on to team up with
spider-man and eventually joined the
Avengers at the request of Thor might I
add
so the groundwork has already been set
up and they MCU for the new character to
come in as nova olives and are is wiped
out so there can only be one person
remaining to receive the fool Nova force
now if you're unfamiliar with Nova's
powers they're pretty great
the Nova force gives him superhuman
powers including flight superhuman
strength speed and durability as well as
the power to absorb energy that's
directed against him and then release it
as pulses and beams and he can do this
out of specific body parts like his
hands
his entire body Nova is definitely going
to be a force to be reckoned with in the
MCU however we're not really sure about
what the character is going to be like
Kevin Feige could choose the Nova force
to go to an adult or a teenager like in
the comics we are getting a Young
Avengers Disney Plus show or film so
there's always a possibility that he
could be a teenager but either way
according to this report Nova is coming
to the MCU most likely a film but we'll
have to wait and see but exciting things
he is coming after all this time so let
me know how pumped you are for this in
the comments down below don't forget to
leave a like and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU and so you can enter my Iron
Man Funko pop giveaway for live updates
you can follow me on Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof